wir schauen einmal auf brutale bilder
aus afghanistan
auf das was jetzt gerade dort in diesem
land passiert wo man 20 jahre für die
demokratie für die freiheit gekämpft hat
wir sehen leichen dort auf der straße
menschen umgebracht von den taliban
die bilder stammen aus der region
kandahar ganz aktuelle bilder dort als
ob es noch beweise gebraucht hätte wie
die taliban eben morden wie sie mit all
jenen umgehen die ihre im islamismus
eben nicht folgen wollen die unsere
werte vertreten oder zumindest annähernd
die dort im verbund mit der bundeswehr
mit den internationalen kräften in den
vergangenen jahren gearbeitet haben also
das sind die bilder dort aktuell aus dem
land das ja fast zu 100 prozent muss man
mittlerweile sagen wieder unter
kontrolle der taliban ist und wir müssen
einmal darüber schon ernsthaft sprechen
julian reichelt paul ronzheimer was man
denn mit diesem land jetzt weitermachen
kann machen möchte also ganz klar ist ja
dass die gesetze die scharia die taliban
dort jetzt wieder eingeführt hat und
weiter einführen wird auch in der
hauptstadt dass das von unseren werten
himmelweit entfernt ist und trotzdem
könnte man natürlich zudem zu der
auffassung gelangen so lange unser
nationales interesse davon nicht berührt
ist dann können wir damit umgehen aber
unser nationales interesse wird in dem
moment auf jeden fall berührt wo sich
zehntausende hunderttausende menschen
auf den weg zu uns nach deutschland
machen ist dass die schwelle für uns
oder ist für dich schon die schwelle
dass du sagst frauen die dort nicht
studieren konnten die die dort studieren
konnten wieder die können all das jetzt
nicht mehr damit können wir das können
wir nicht so stehen lassen also ich
glaube zunächst muss man sagen dass
neben den deutschen die dort mal so mit
einem deutschen pass noch festsitzen ist
auch viele gibt die für deutschland
gearbeitet haben die für deutschland
alles riskiert haben und die auch immer
noch nicht raus geholt wurden da gab es
bereits vor wochen immer wieder die
aussage von denen menschen mir gegenüber
die gesagt haben wissen gar nicht wie
wir uns informieren sollen die botschaft
die deutsche botschaft ist geschlossen
dann gab es einen fall über den wir
berichtet haben ein kirchenbauer der
bundeswehr kirche im camp marmal in
masar i scharif der beauftragten wurde
der wurde nicht anerkannt obwohl
natürlich derjenige in eine kirche baut
ganz offensichtlich besonders bedroht
ist von den taliban also das noch mal
dazu ich glaube neben der frage wie
risikoreich ist die situation jetzt für
die deutschen staatsbürger ist es auch
ein großes versagen was die
unterstützung der menschen angeht die
einen afghanischen pass haben aber für
deutschland gearbeitet haben das ist das
eine thema das heißt ich glaube da muss
die regierung jetzt wirklich ganz ganz
schnell intensiv handeln um auch
diejenigen rauszubekommen die zweite
frage die duh gestellt hast ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass die taliban
flüchtlinge einsetzen werden auch als
verhandlungsmasse also dass sie
sozusagen da druck machen werden auf
deutschland und auf internationale
starten dass sie sagen wir brauchen eure
hilfsgelder wir brauchen eure
entwicklungshilfe ansonsten machen wir
die grenzen auf zunächst richtung iran
das kann uns vielleicht noch ein
bisschen egal sein aber dann weiter
richtung türkei und nach deutschland
also wir werden jetzt auch im wahlkampf
eine große debatte erleben was machen
wir mit diesen flüchtlingen denn ganz
klar ist kai abgeschoben wird ganz
sicher nicht mehr schon alleine deshalb
weil man in ein paar tagen oder wochen
gar nicht mehr weiß wo man dann soll ja
also das zeigt ja längst den
abschiebestopp jetzt auch hopplahopp
eigentlich beschlossen nachdem man erst
wenige tage vor noch explizit anderer
auffassung war jetzt der abschiebestopp
beschlossen das heißt dass die
sogenannten ehrenmorde
eben in deutschland bleiben eine
dauerkarte bekommen haben weil unsere
bundeswehrsoldaten und die
internationalen truppen abgezogen sind
na ja das ist ja das worüber wir die
letzten monate im prinzip seit 2015 die
letzten jahre immer gesprochen haben die
formulierung lautet fluchtursachen vor
ort bekämpfen und zu eurer frage ist es
in unserem strategischen interesse dass
frauen in afghanistan zur universität
gehen können das mädchen zur schule
gehen können es ist sicher in unsere
moralischen interesse ist es im
interesse unserer werte ist es in einem
ersten schritt in unserem strategischen
interesse darüber kann man diskutieren
es wäre wünschenswert und deutsche
soldaten haben dafür ihr leben gelassen
was in unserem strategischen interesse
ist ist ein stabiles afghanistan aus dem
zwei dinge nicht hervorgehen terror und
flüchtlingsbewegungen deswegen hat man
seit 2015 immer wieder gesagt wir müssen
fluchtursachen vor ort.de kämpfen nicht
uns weg wünschen nicht hoffen dass sie
nicht auftreten bekämpfen das gegenteil
davon hat die bundes hat die
bundesregierung mit beschlossen mit wird
getragen das was wir im moment sehen die
bilder erinnern uns ja was heißt
erinnern da waren wir noch nicht auf der
welt aber wir kennen sie natürlich aus
den geschichtsbüchern die bot die
hubschrauber die über der us-botschaft
in santa fe das was wir dort im moment
sehen ist nichts anderes als eine
kapitulation des mächtigsten
militärbündnisses der welt vor einer
steinzeit armee die leider inzwischen
sehr gut ausgestattet ist und das was
dort jetzt natürlich passieren wird ist
dass es 1 1 regime geben wird ein
kalifat geben wird das den schlimmsten
terrororganisationen dieser welt zu
flucht und ein operationsraum gewähren
wird und gleichzeitig werden sich
natürlich all die menschen die sich an
dieses wunderschöne leben was wir ihnen
ja ermöglicht haben durch den einsatz
unserer truppen gewöhnt haben die dieses
leben weiterleben wollen die werden
natürlich versuchen afghanistan zu
verlassen die werden hier herkommen die
werden in erster linie nach deutschland
wollen das wissen wir und das ist das
direkte und unmittelbare
versagen unserer regierung die uns ja
das gegenteil gesagt hat die gesagt hat
unsere strategie nach 2015 nach der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 ist fluchtursachen
vor ort bekämpfen nichts davon ist
umgesetzt worden angela merkel wird das
in kanzler rente dann betrachten die
konsequenzen dieser politik aber dieses
land wird sie ausbaden müssen und das
ist abgesehen von all dem menschlichen
leid und elend was sich in den nächsten
tagen und wochen in afghanistan
abspielen wird gegen minderheiten aber
eben auch gegen frauen abgesehen davon
dass ist der die die bittere botschaft
dieser stunde also das drama spielt sich
in afghanistan ab aber es kommt eben
auch zu uns nach deutschland in form von
flüchtlingen und in form von neuem
weiterem terror reichelt terror ein
stichwort k unser kollege europe hat
gerade recherchierte die taliban 5000
gefangene am flughafen markram befreit
haben und darunter auch führende al
kaida terroristen die dort seit 20
jahren inhaftiert waren also so viel zu
der frage inwieweit uns wieder
terrorismus der wohl nicht weiter dort
entwickelt wird ganz wichtiger punkt der
flughafen bagdad wir wollen unseren
zuschauern später hier glaube ich auch
noch kartenmaterial zeigen damit dass
meine einordnung darüber gibt was
passiert da gerade in der stadt wo ist
die deutsche botschaft wo ist der
flughafen das werden wir später noch
nachrichten aber die airbase wagram
wagram erfassbar ist war eine der
wichtigsten rrv spaces der vereinigten
staaten ausserhalb der usa von dort
wurde der gesamte afghanistan einsatz
quasi gesteuert von dort wurden
luftschläge zum beispiel gegen taliban
gruppen geflogen aber bei kam air force
base war eben auch so etwas wie das
vermutlich wichtigere aber deutlich
weniger bekannte guantanamo das war ein
militärgefängnis mit höchsten
sicherheitsstandards in dem
kämpfer al-kaida-anführer taliban für
islamisten aus der ganzen region über
jahre als kriegsgefangene das heißt auch
ohne prozess gefangen gehalten wurden
und die
freuen sich heute alle über ihre freier
stehen die türen mittlerweile offen
[Musik]
sieben weitere bedrückende neuigkeiten
aus afghanistan direkt patricia
präsident gar nie hat das land verlassen
heißt es jetzt eben gerade in diesen
sekunden er soll geflohen sein
afghanische präsidentschaft die hat in
einem medienbericht zufolge das land
verlassen er soll
auf dem weg nach tadschikistan sich
jetzt bisschen das genau dass patricia
kann man sagen bild wusste schon vor 20
minuten worüber wir gesprochen haben der
präsident hat sich auch nach unseren
informationen erst per helikopter vom
präsidentenpalast abgesetzt wir haben
ashraf ghani zuletzt 2018 interview dort
das ist ein sehr weitläufiges gelände
bestens geschützt seine gaals die ihn
bis zuletzt bewacht haben aber präsident
gar nie musste zuletzt auch um sein
leben fürchten denn auch innerhalb des
präsidentenpalastes gab es leute die
sich gegen ihn gewandt haben und es gab
dort bodyguards von ashraf ghani die aus
regionen kommen wo die taliban besonders
stark sind und es gab die mutmaßung dass
möglicherweise auch ein anschlag auf ihn
passieren könnte dann in der
vergangenheit sind so immer wieder auch
mächtige politiker auch mächtige
staatschef sozusagen umgekommen er hat
sich dann zusammen mit seinem engsten
team ich war mit seinem chief of staff
zuletzt gestern in kontakt wo immer noch
der versuch war was können wir schaffen
es war klar dass er zurücktreten würde
aber die idee des präsidenten war dass
er zusammen mit den taliban an einem
tisch sitzt und über wahlen entscheidet
also ein übergangspräsident wurde
eingesetzt da werden jetzt
unterschiedliche namen gehandelt unter
anderem der des vorherigen präsidenten
herrn kasai in deutschland gut bekannt
viele bilder mit der kanzlerin wir
wissen auch dass die kanzlerin im
übrigen einen sehr engen draht zu rasch
auf gar nicht gepflegt hat und die
kanzlerin so höre ich aus dem umfeld des
afghanischen präsidenten hat in einem
der letzten telefonate mit ihm gesagt
das ist für deutschland sehr wichtig ist
dass das land eben nicht an die taliban
geht denn so berichten dass die
afghanischen quellen wie sollen sie das
den deutschen erklären dass 20 jahre
bundeswehreinsatz umsonst gewesen sein
also sehr spannend die kanzlerin hat
erschafft gar nicht immer wieder sehr
unterstützt man muss ihn sich vorstellen
als eher
intellektuellen präsidenten er saß fiel
zuletzt in seiner bücherei war isoliert
auch ein bisschen von der außenwelt
berater die mit ihm zu tun haben sagen
er war nicht mehr erreichbar für die
realität die eigentlich im land passiert
ist er hat das so ein bisschen versucht
auszublenden eigentlich wie viele
regionen gefallen sind auffällig war
auch dass in den letzten sechs bis acht
wochen keine interviews gegeben hat man
hat ihn fast nie gesehen in der
öffentlichkeit und jetzt ist er geflohen
das ist ein tragisches ende erst ein
zweites mal wiedergewählt worden er hat
jetzt noch eigentlich drei jahre vor
sich gehabt aber er hat auch nie
geschafft sozusagen die afghanische
armee zu motivieren man hat keine
ansprache gehalten leute geht nach
draußen kämpft für euer land sondern er
war und umklammert ein bisschen im
würgegriff seiner berater und die
menschen haben in das übel genommen wie
sich das land entwickelt hat dass er die
korruption eben nicht bekämpft hat so
intensiv wie er es versprochen hat und
vor allem auch dass die museen heute
ganz kurz von euch beiden mit ihm ja es
erinnert ihr euch an den moment damals
ja ein sehr sympathischer mann das war
wie gesagt 2018 und damals haben wir
ganz viel mit ihm über flüchtlinge
gesprochen und er hat davor gewarnt der
damals gewarnt und hat gesagt die
straßen in deutschland sind nicht aus
gold gepflastert und diese vorurteile
die es dort gibt hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen dass die jungen menschen
im land bleiben und hat gesagt wir
stehen vor einer guten zukunft gut wir
sehen was daraus geworden ist
interessanter punkt wenn man diesen
palast in kabul besucht das foto zeigt
der paul und mich im palast im
präsidentenpalast von kabul da hat man
sicherheitsringe um diesen klassen die
eigentlich einem schon ganz klar sagen
dass dieser mann der präsident von
afghanistan der scherzhaft auch der
bürgermeister von kabul geplant wird im
land überhaupt keine macht hat und sich
ausschließlich mit waffengewalt über
jahre davor schützen konnte im nächsten
moment von attentätern der taliban oder
anderen islamisten umgebracht zu werden
das was paul eben gesagt hat die
afghanische armee die ja immer
beschworen worden ist die
kernbestandteil unserer strategie weil
diese afghanische armee und das war
immer klar das war jedem beobachter klar
es war jedem journalisten klar der dort
war das war jedem klar der diesen unfug
muss man sagen nicht in
regierungsverantwortung erzählen musste
und das erzählt hat weil er in
regierungsverantwortung und es selber
glauben wollte inklusive all unserer
außenminister inklusive unserer
verteidigungsminister inklusive unserer
kanzlerin die afghanische armee hat noch
nie existiert die afghanische armee als
armee die einen nationalstaat beschützt
sie sagt ich bin afghane hat niemals
existiert die haben immer existiert als
sollt empfänger als leute die sich gerne
haben bezahlen lassen vom staat aber
niemals als an
[Musik]